foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where that is dumb
cash is King in the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Christina Ellis Ram Z personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today she and I will be answering your
questions about your life and your money
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Rebecca's with us in Flint Michigan hi
Rebecca welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um sorry I'm a little nervous it's okay
you'll be all right we've never lost a
patient
um
I've been grooming for 12 years now
and uh been doing mobile grooming
started my own business six years ago
during the pandemic in 2020 I shut down
and was going through
um a rough divorce and moved to be
closer to my support system and my
family
um when I reopened I kept my old some of
my old clients
um
but it's time to let them go my business
is booming and I have people waiting to
get in with me
um I just don't know how to let them go
without
[Music]
um
without disappointing them and without
leaving myself open to
um caving in so I I can see myself
telling them hey you guys had me till
June after June you're gonna have to
find another groomer and I'm going we'll
pay you more money we'll do whatever we
can to keep you when it just needs to be
a severed tie so I'm calling Dave to see
if you can if you have any tools or
advice on how I tackle that what's going
on with the old clients why do they need
to be severed too far away it's it's
nothing it's nothing to do with them
they're good clients
um they're an hour away so now I'm
within 20 minutes of home I have a kid
in school
um so once a week I'm driving an hour
I'm grooming all of them they're
fantastic on keeping their appointments
and that it's just it's the drive back
and forth when I could be making the
same amount of money if not more close
to home well and you're also losing all
that time
which is important even if you got paid
for it it's still not the way to live
your life exactly I that's why I don't
want to leave myself for money yeah
here's the thing it's a very simple
thing you just say it's too far a drive
after my divorce I moved and I'm way
away and I'm not able to do clients
anymore that aren't within this uh range
oh well I want you to come anyway I'm
sorry I just wish I could but I can't
well I'll pay you double I'm sorry I
just wish I could but I can't
and it's just I mean no is a complete
sentence Rebecca I mean
yeah it's getting that no I've been
grooming
grooming I don't care I mean there's
things you you outgrow things things
change in life and if their life
revolves around their dog groomer they
need to grow a real life
[Laughter]
for them to drive to her
if you want to do that that's fine yeah
if you want to I thought about that that
can make that that kind of puts a wrench
in things because if they're late or
don't show up now I'm sitting I'm trying
to find some place to groom from the
whole point of being mobile is uh
convenience for the client I show up and
groom your dog so you don't wonder
yeah it doesn't make sense you know and
so you know uh we had a lady that
cleaned our house and her husband moved
to Oklahoma and she wanted to go with
her husband so she can't clean her house
anymore
because she's not going to come from
Oklahoma to clean her house and you know
it was she's a sweet lady she's been
with us for years we love her she's like
a family member in a sense but she's not
a family member and um anybody with
common sense knows that you're not going
to come from Oklahoma to Nashville to
clean a house it doesn't make sense so
and that's the same discussion it's just
you know you're gonna you're gonna have
one or two that are unreasonable
emotional people but that's just because
they're unreasonable emotional people
and you're just gonna have to say I
can't do it now I'm assuming you have
enough you said your business is booming
you got enough business lined up you
don't need them
oh no I going out there is is literally
I don't want to disappoint them it's
literally you don't know how to say that
yeah yeah exactly so I mean you just I'm
so sorry I just can't you know the other
thing you could do is do you have a a
former competitor in that area that you
could recommend with good conscience I
don't that that would make it easier to
say here's somebody to go to I there's
not a whole lot of groomers it's out
it's a very rural area out there yeah
what I can relate to your concerns is
somebody who you know Enneagram three
doesn't like to make people unhappy you
know those conversations can be kind of
nerve-wracking but if it helps you may
want to even like write out a script
before you go into the call where it's
like you know here are my boundaries
here's what I'm going to say so that
once you get in it you know no matter
what they say even if they're like oh
man and start making you feel bad you've
really thought through kind of the
boundaries and what you want to say and
the big thing you got to think about is
this when I get off the phone there's
only one result
it's over
okay
breaking up is hard to do but it's up
it's over
it's over we're not there's no
negotiation there's no you're not
attempting to get anything else out of
this you're simply notifying them that
after June
little Fluffy's gonna have to get his
hair cut by somebody else pretty simple
and they'll be okay they're gonna be all
right they'll be all right I mean we the
Rufus the Shih Tzu at Ramsey Place gets
a Mobile Groomer that comes in and cuts
his shitsu hair off which definitely
needs to happen and uh you know I don't
don't we we don't have like this
in-depth familial relationship with the
dog groomer it's okay I mean they're cut
the dogs here that's what they do it's
okay Dave don't make this bigger and
bigger than it is it's just you know
just no I can't cut their hair anymore
just like that yeah even if you run into
intense dog dads which apparently is a
thing now well I mean I don't there
aren't the only dog dads are other dogs
other dogs make little dogs so we need
to keep this in mind but yeah it's a
little bit out of control I'm kind of
with baloney on this one all right
Joseph is with us in uh Austin Texas hi
Joseph welcome to the Ramsey Show
how you doing Mr Ramsey I really
appreciate you calling me and uh my
cousin Calvin been listening to you for
a long time so it's greatly appreciated
thank you thank you sir how can we help
okay so I'm 19 years old I'm in the Army
um I'm in college I'm about to get out
in uh uh two years and some change
um my plan is to my ultimate goal is to
buy a house when I get out of the army
I'm gonna go back home to New Jersey New
York City area and I get basic housing
allowance which is 3 500 bucks for four
years I have about 25 000 saved up and
my plan is to uh or you know go during
that four years you're getting the 3500
stipend because you're going to be
getting your education correct
yeah every month yeah good for you hey
thanks for your service it sounds like a
good plan no I would not buy a house
while you're going through school
just be a college student a 21 year old
college student government's giving you
housing allowance you got some money to
cover rent and just go to school just go
to school don't get in the house
business go to get the college
graduation business
focus on one thing because after you get
out of college it's highly unlikely
you're going to be in that area so let's
make a decision to just rent right now
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today the countdown to Christmas
is on and you have less than two days
left to get free shipping and to get
your gifts in time for Christmas go to
ramseysolutions.com check out our new
Ramsay apparel we've got teas hoodies
sweatshirts all with your favorite
Ramsay one-liners like live like no one
else or cash is king or better than I
deserve and also check out questions for
humans conversation cards uh we have
sold out of the Christmas Version we've
sold out of the New Year's version but
we have the brand new regular second
edition there is available which will
work just fine for your holiday get
together and the Ramsey gold planner is
out there and the Rachel Cruz red wallet
is out there uh you have until December
8th just a couple of days to get free
shipping and have your gifts in time for
Christmas ramseysolutions.com head on
over there today so NPR somebody said me
the link today I guess I was our
producer James Senate NPR Stacy Smith a
writer for NPR has a full article about
a young lady paying off eighteen
thousand dollars worth of credit card
debt not making a lot of money as a
journalism living in Brooklyn and uh she
did
this new craze that is sweeping the
nation
apparently gen Z has uh has a brand new
fad out called
um cash stuffing
it's a tick tock craze living on cash
on the envelope system
it's called Cash stuffing such a New
Concept oh it's brand new just came out
the Tic Tac guys just figured it out and
so
um it's fun though I'm glad that I'm
glad she did it so she learned how to do
the envelope system we I I heard about
the envelope system uh 36 years ago the
first time from a guy named Larry
Burkett and it and I have a collection
of antique
envelope systems from the 30s the 20s
the 40s and the 50s it was quite the
thing there was little envelope systems
like Rachel Cruz's wallet had the red
wallet that we have in the store right
now all the colors but the brand new red
one also it has pockets in it that you
label with uh categories in your budget
and some things in your budget from the
very first day I started teaching this
Larry Burkett stole it from your
grandmother I stole it from Larry
Burkett and your grandmother uh we've
been teaching people to do um the
envelope system which now is called Cash
stuffing if you're a cool gen Z tic
Tacker so um
that's how that works and so here's how
cash stuffing now that I know what you
call it here's how the envelope system
that we've taught for 40 years works
it's pretty simple you have some
categories in your budget
and they should be mostly if not all
categories of things you spend when you
are not
paying bills you're away from your desk
you're away from your home so a grocery
store
could be car gas
could be entertainment
budget it could be a restaurant budget
and I do recommend when you first start
your budget separate restaurants and
groceries because it'll make you realize
what you're spending on restaurants and
so what we taught people to do and we
still teach people to do this I just
didn't know it was cool again I mean if
you keep your clothes long enough they
come back just ask James I mean it's um
come back from the 90s right so um but
the uh
so the idea is I'm going to spend X
number of dollars for this pay period
on groceries I'll make up a number
500 bucks 400 bucks whatever the number
is you actually get that much cash out
of your paycheck and put the actual real
dollars into the envelope marked
groceries or in the original Cruise
envelope system that and you label it
groceries and then you don't buy any
groceries except out of that envelope
and you don't buy anything out of that
envelope except groceries it makes you
keep your categories clean and true and
oh by the way when you uh are out of
money in that category
stop buying
and so this young lady goes to the
grocery store in this article with 46
dollars
to in the grocery store forty six
dollars cash for the week uh apparently
for the month I no no it's for the week
okay and I believe
I mean but she's like I have to stay
away from the fancy olive oil aisle
because I really you're you're in for
that stuff and I I'm not going to get it
and uh and she's buying day old bread
and gets a whole thing a loaf of bread
and she's like okay that's 20 slices
that means I get 10 peanut butter and
jellies out of that and so you know and
she's going down 2.36 80 cents six
dollars and 38 cents and as she's
walking through she knows she can't go
over forty six dollars because that's
what's in her food envelope well and it
feels different when you're spending
Cold Hard Cash like when you actually
are handing over something in that
transaction that you don't get back
there's an emotional attachment to it
well you know the Studies have shown uh
and one of the best studies I was done
at MIT is they were studying the the
brain wave and when you brainwave
activity and when you spend with real
cash it activates the pain centers of
the brain when you spin with plastic
nothing no brain but um yeah but anyway
no I mean it's just dead there's no but
you're so in other words you have an
ouchy moment
when you spend cash because you have a
realization and you're right Rachel Cruz
pointed out years ago and I had never
thought of it but she and I were doing
an event together and she pointed out
when you hand you know you think about
when you were a kid if you wanted to
trade
one of your toys
to another kid for their toy so there's
a trade there's a transaction you give
them yours that you don't get it back
they give you theirs and so that's what
happens with cash
we hand over president faces and we
leave with a loaf of bread
so there's a there's a transaction
there's a handy you give up something
and you leave with something
visually that doesn't happen when you
spin with plastic you give them the
plastic
they hand you the plastic back
and the loaf of bread
there's no transaction visually to your
point earlier and there's that sounds so
uh primitive but it activates those
parts of the brain and you have to
understand personal finance is 80
Behavior it's only 20 head knowledge so
when you put systems in place that help
you manage your behavior you are you you
you're it's a life hack you're you're
cutting you're cutting a corner and
making it work well that's part of you
know when people say I can keep credit
cards and I pay them off every month
they're I mean I'm not going to argue
with the people who say that they can do
that but do you spend more when you do
that do you not have that pain center go
off like if you were actually spending
cash would you be a little bit more
hesitant to buy that extra shirt to buy
that extra purchase that you maybe don't
need uh well studies prove that you
spend 12 to 18 percent more using
plastic than using cash I mean we've got
tons of research on this this is not a a
new phenomenon and in in the digital
world we call it friction
the the easier it is without realizing
you spent money without too many steps
then boom you know you hit the PayPal
clean boom Oh Amazon you you click on
your card is already on file and you
just click Buy
and there's no I mean no recognition
that money's actually spent the weird
thing is is the studies also show that
when you use a debit card versus a
credit card
that there's more
physical physiological reaction
recognition I better have the money in
that account otherwise I just bounced a
check
when I use my debit card
right yeah otherwise I've just gone into
overdraft and there's a physical a
physiological recognition of that in
your body and in your brain versus when
you lay the plastic down you're just
like we'll figure it out later
[Music]
Temptation keeps getting even higher
because we've got we've got we've got
venmo where you can just transfer money
so easy you know a friend's gonna be
like I'll pick up dinner and you can
just send the money we've got Amazon
where it's one click ordering it's like
everything it's getting so easy to spend
so it's like even even if you're using a
debit card I think it's getting more and
more important to create boundaries
around your spending so that you feel it
so that you know even if it's an easy
transaction there's a little bit of pain
or a little bit of boundaries to keep
you in line here's the other side of the
equation retired school teacher retired
Methodist Pastor 3.7 million net worth
December of 2021 where debt free
multi-millionaires drowning in a cosmic
ocean of Grace giving is the most fun we
can have not involving fat sugar or
chocolate
[Laughter]
we're childless but we have 16 kids that
we support so we have 16 children
very cool see that's that's what happens
when you stuff catch
what's up
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
[Music]
Christine Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Jim and
Ashley are with us hey guys how are you
good how are you guys better than we
deserve where do you guys live we live
in Clarksville Tennessee oh just up the
road cool well welcome to Nashville good
to have you thank you and how much debt
have you guys paid off 625 thousand
dollars oh wow how long did that take 30
months okay there's a story here what's
your range of income during that two and
a half years we started around forty
five thousand and ended at 67 plus aside
so or excuse me 60 000 plus a seven
thousand dollar side hustle gotcha what
do you all do for a living I am an
office manager at Crow Estate Planning
and probate
and I'm a stay-at-home dad cool good for
you okay how do you get rid of six
hundred thousand dollars on forty five
thousand dollars income that doesn't
work
you must have sold the house we sold our
rental in California ah okay all right
and and what did it sell for it sold for
8 10 and we used uh some of that money
to pay off our house in in Clarksville
Tennessee that's fun yeah what's the
house in Clarksville worth
um I think it's about 325. okay very
good very cool good for you guys okay so
you pay you paid that off and do you
have any other debt nope that was it
you're just now officially weird people
no mortgages paid for house and
everything we we did have
um we also paid off 55 000
um in the combined total of
um student loans credit cards a car and
uh we had a Turf payment oh you did have
other debt okay we did all right cool
all right cool so we knocked all of that
out and the mortgage with the sale of
the rental correct that's simple and it
took 30 months to sell it
uh we started for the first 55 000 that
was about the first year and a half
um and the last little bit was just kind
of getting the house sold and
um and just kind of
letting the money go to pay off that
house so you kind of didn't want to sell
the rental at first
no we thought renting was going to you
know renting was going to be fun and
um it's you know passive income
um and it honestly it kind of turned out
to be a nightmare yeah not bad so um I
mean well you managed to do it right in
the middle of covid too
yeah yeah that kind of um you know we
always thought maybe we would go back to
California that's where we're originally
from uh we moved out here shortly after
we got married and we're like you know
maybe we'll go back maybe we won't and
then we kind of looked at each other and
said
are we really going to go back
so what got you started on the Ramsay
way
well in about 2020
um I started with the podcast
and
um about a month or so in I had uh sent
a text message to a mentor that I had
and I said hey I'm listening to the
James Ramsey show what do you think
about this guy you know I'm interested
to hear your piece and he said
you know Dave's a great guy keep
listening and so that kind of got me
hooked I bought The Total Money Makeover
shortly after and
like I said the rest is history wow very
cool just like that so actually uh he's
got the podcast going is he giving you a
hard time
um he's we've talked about reading me
reading the book and um he pretty much
just every day I'd come home and he'd
talk about the plan and the baby steps
and then you know we would talk about
knocking each one of them out and then
he he listens to the podcast every day
and so I'm when we're in the car we
listen to it or we watch it on YouTube
so there's no fun anymore
it's really cool though to see everybody
you know come from different walks of
life and really stick with the plan and
be able to pay everything off yeah it's
awesome so you you sold the house what
else did y'all do in this journey
because you mentioned the side hustle a
7K side hustle what was that so we
cleaned my offices that I work for um in
Clarksville and in Hopkinsville okay
that's awesome so what would you say is
the key because there's a lot of people
who are looking at that number thinking
whoa that that's impressive what's the
key to getting out of debt
um you know Stephen Covey has a really
good uh quote that says uh begin with
the end in mind and our definitely end
goal was
to be stress-free to really you know
like I said and live like no one else so
that you know we could live like no one
else
um and I think that was our biggest goal
we wanted to change our family tree we
didn't want to be like everybody else
um you know because Normal sucks amen
good for you guys well done hey we're
proud of you who are your biggest
cheerleaders
each other and our families we have
Jim's mom here from California to
celebrate with us today as well very fun
awesome good stuff we got the live and
give bundle for you that's The Total
Money Makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book that's the next
chapter in your story and a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
the brand new version that has George
and Rachel and deloney and me and
everybody's in it so be sure and watch
that through if you haven't or give it
all away or whatever you want to do it's
for you it's the live and give bundle so
very very proud of you all right what's
your uh your child's name and age let's
get them get him in the shot here his
name is James and he will be two in
January all right so James came uh just
about well right in the middle of all
this
yes yeah yeah that's part of the deal
huh good job all right fun stuff I love
it all right Jim and Ashley and James
Clarksville Tennessee 625 000 paid off
in 30 months making 45 to 67. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
three two one
[Applause]
that is how it's done I love it Wendy is
with us in Omaha Nebraska hi Wendy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you for taking my call I
appreciate that
so um the reason why I'm calling is I
wanted to know if um my ideas of moving
to Japan to be close to my grandma is a
good financially good idea I'm a school
teacher for the past two 20 years and I
raised all my three kids as a single mom
so I don't really have much of a
retirement other than the 403b that I
received from the school
um so then I do own a house I mean I
think I still owe about 98 000 but it's
worth about 275 000. good how old are
you
um 49. cool so you want to go to Japan
and do what
um be maybe administrator I do have a
two
months agree so
into an international school or
something and getting into
Administration you'd be near your
grandmother you'd be making a lot of
money a lot more than you make now right
I'm hoping to no I wouldn't go if you
don't because it's very High Cost of
Living
all right and so I mean I I talked to a
guy yesterday as a matter of fact that
it was in the I.T world and he moved his
family and they lived in Japan for three
years and the co the company worked for
furnished all housing and they doubled
his income and so they looked at it as a
short-term adventure and He piled up a
huge pile of cash in a short period of
time but if you're going to go over
there and make the same amount of money
and the cost of living be twice as much
as it is where you are no thank you I
don't want to do that
okay
okay what do you make now
um I make a 7D you should make 100 and a
half with it with a masters in
administrative yeah I haven't tried for
the administrative positions yet so I
mean I but no I wouldn't go over there
and make the same you're going to go
backward if you do
what about your kids you're gonna leave
them behind right
right well they're older you know they
don't count anymore
yeah well youngest one is still with me
but
but then like I'm also concerned about
my house I do have four bedroom home all
right
how long are you gonna be in Japan
um well my grandma's 92 so I just didn't
want her to be alone how long are you
gonna be in Japan
maybe five years sell your house
okay buy another one when you come home
you don't want to manage a rental
property or an empty house
internationally you'll take all the fun
out of this experience
so what do I do with the money that I
get from the house because put it in an
investment to buy a house with when you
get back
all of them
all of them all the money
like all of the well I'm thinking like
150 000 I'd probably just put it in some
good mutual funds and so it'll be there
when you get home and it will have grown
and you'll be able to buy another house
and you're gonna make a whole bunch of
money so you're going to add to that
investment while you're going to Japan
or you don't go
that's what I would do
well and with this couple that just paid
off you know they're dead they they
didn't want to stay in the rental
business and managing that while in
Japan
so much wrong with this this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey guys thank you for joining us
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today if you like this show and
you want to help us out we would
appreciate the help we do need the help
we need you to do three things regarding
the show number one if you watch the
show on YouTube subscribe if you listen
on a podcast subscribe versus just
dialing in and checking it out the
subscriptions change the algorithms on
the internet and on the different
platforms and it serves it up to more
and more people to be recommended if
you're subscribing so thank you for that
leaving a review does the same thing
five star reviews only please thank you
very much and share this show if you're
listening on talk radio tell your
friends about your local radio station
to tune in and of course you've got
share functions on Spotify or apple or
YouTube that you can actually send the
link and click a share button whatever
however that particular platform works
but but help us spread the word
it turns out all of our internal data
indicates by far our best promotional
thing to help us get the word out of
this information is you telling someone
about it you are a big deal thank you we
appreciate you Jared is in Altoona
Pennsylvania hi Jared welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave and Christina I hope you guys
are having a good day today we are how
can we help
um yeah so my question kind of in a
whole package deal today is
um my grandparents had their retirement
funds in a annuity that matured after 10
years right and
um about around last year I looked into
what the retirement plan was and it
looked like that their retirement was
basically getting zero interest per year
on that annuity but they were still
still taking out
um their their fees and their expenses
that the service that they had it in and
so I decided that I was going to manage
their funds for them and I decided to
pull that retirement out and roll it
over into a traditional IRA but doing
that it was a five percent penalty
because it was only five years into the
annuity and it was supposed oh you made
that up in one year
that was brilliant
yes yeah if they were making sure and
you moved them into mutual funds making
10 or 12 they made 10 or 12 first year
they lost five so they only netted seven
after that they make 10 or 12. so
absolutely I would have done that
the only thing is it was around last
year and now the market crash oh this
Market didn't crash the market went down
and it hadn't come back up but I mean
overall over the scope of their lives
unless they die this year this is a
brilliant move
but no I mean you you know the market
can come up and down but the average of
the market is has been 11.8 percent
since it started
mm-hmm and so let you know let's say you
cost them five and you made them eleven
then you made them a net of six
now this year you may or may not do that
um probably not in 2022 but 2023 you'll
be fine 24 there you know you're gonna
be just fine I mean some years you could
make 17 right I mean it's it's an
average
yeah I guess I was just nervous because
you know I transferred it all over they
they dropped I mean there's probably a
hundred K in it and then you know five
five grand off the top just came off of
that well and then they lost another
point and then they lost another 12 or
13. yeah yeah but but it's not you know
you didn't lose it until you cash it in
right no one gets hurt on a roller
coaster except those that jump off
during the ride
yeah you did the right thing Jared okay
that's what exactly what I would have
done
all right perfect that's all I want to
hear okay
yeah that's hard yeah thank you so the
important thing to remember it folks is
this you cannot take a single snapshot
when the Market's down and use that to
make your judgments about your long-term
Investments that's a moment in time you
can't take a single snapshot when the
Market's way up and go well I made 23 on
my money last year which I've had years
I made more than that you know well but
but that's not the norm I mean you can't
count on 23 no but you can count on the
averages well and Jared I didn't ask his
age but he sounds young and if he's gen
Z Millennial this may be his first time
seeing the market go down significantly
so it is kind of scary if you've you
know gone through this season with covid
where it's been lots of highs and a lot
of people been winning in the market and
then all of a sudden it goes down it's
easy to go oh my gosh I've never seen
this before but somebody like Dave
you've talked about how you've seen the
roller coaster throughout the years
somebody are you saying I'm old
but I know like Dave yeah but I mean
seriously that's it pan back from the
moment and get not only a little bit of
the future in your peripheral vision but
a whole bunch of the past in your
peripheral vision and you see the trend
across something more than one month or
one year
because if you take a one month or one
year Trend in any investment and use
that to make your decisions you're going
to make a bad decision now I wonder too
if some of that anxiety he was feeling
was the fact that it's his grandparents
you know money and they're they're
probably needing that money right now
what would you say to that concern of
you know if it was Jared's money
specifically it'd be a lot easier to go
okay I'm not worried about it I'm not
going to retire for four years here's
the thing if you left it where it was it
was sucking
for sure it was gonna go it was gonna
you know it's costing money every year
sitting where it is he did the right
thing his anxiety is is that he just
wanted to make sure
he did the right thing for sure but for
retirees right now who are feeling
really nervous about the market what
would you say to them you don't need the
money
um when you retire with a million
dollars you don't cash a million dollars
out and set it at the kitchen table you
leave the million dollars in the
investment you live off the income and
so if this year you didn't the
investment didn't go up and so by taking
some money okay let's take let's do this
let's take the hundred thousand okay uh
Market's down fifteen percent all right
and you were you want to live on ten
percent of your Investments so if you
had a hundred thousand dollars you want
to live on ten thousand dollars okay so
you pull out ten thousand dollars you
got 90 and it loses fifteen percent so
you're down 25 percent
okay
now
the next year it comes up
10 15 percent
comes right back up and you still pull
off ten thousand dollars
if you keep doing that math every year
up and down up and down up and down and
it averages 10 or 11 percent and you're
pulling off ten percent you will get to
even you'll get back to the hundred and
the hundred will just sit there over
time some Years it'll be 110 some Years
it'll be 90.
and it'll be back and forth right but
you're pulling off 10 the whole time and
it's just gonna it's gonna vacillate
back and forth so you're going to be
just fine and so that that's the thing
it goes down but it's not down
permanently so it'll keep coming up and
they can live off the income so the
point is you never in any of this case
took out the hundred
all you took out was the amount you need
to live on
and then it went down a little and then
when it comes back it has it needs to
come back the amount you took out plus
how much it lost before you're back to
your hundred and it will over time it
will over time I mean and if it didn't
it'll be the first time in history
Brandon is with us Brandon is in uh
Raleigh North Carolina hi Brandon
welcome to the Ramsay show go fast I'm
short on time I got you Dave well thank
you so much for taking my call
um basically my question is is when I
was in college back to a bunch of
student debt we're halfway through it
um and during college my mom promised to
help me take care of the parent Plus
Loans that she took out
um and you know as the holidays come up
it's you know really started to lay down
on me and wanted to know what your
thoughts are on that and or if it's a
conversation to re-bring up uh what
would that look like because uh we're
halfway and it's just been been a really
long journey all right I'm confused your
mom has a parent plus loan
yes for my school so yeah Parent Plus
Loans are in her name and she took that
loan out and she said she was going to
pay it
she's not helping me pay it pretty much
match what I pay or 50 50 split and now
she doesn't want to
or she just it's just something that's
gotten swept under the rug and she
hasn't taken responsibility to help me
or pay it well I think we're talking
about it you took this loan out it's in
your name I can't just leave it at your
doorstep
your mom it's not your name Brandon
mm-hmm I mean anything you do to help
her pay her loan
is because you made an agreement and you
should honor that agreement but you're
not legally liable in any way for this
loan
it's a Parent PLUS Loan it's in her name
and so I think we give her a little
wake-up call my point mom you have a
loan yeah she needs to be feeling some
of that heaviness too yeah you have a
loan
we promised each other that we would
work that loan off together I'm not
going to knock that loan off by myself
because you have a loan and I think some
some version of that with more kindness
than I have in my voice right now is how
your holiday discussion sounds this is
the Ramsay show
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsey show where debt is done cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Christina
Alice Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Melissa in
Texas starts off this hour hi Melissa
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave I'm excited to be on your show I
listen to you a lot when I'm in the
tractor thank you great better than we
deserve Merry Christmas to you
thank you um I have an investment
question
okay
um you say stay with what you know
well the only stock I know anything
about is livestock
we have uh what I would consider to be a
small beef operation
and then we do my husband and I do hoof
trimming
um
as a like a real job so we're recently
got our we have our land our house we're
debt free we very recently we got our
tractors and everything paid off
congratulations
Hoof Trimming is very uh it's it's a
cattle Hoof Trimming job so it's very
labor intensive and we're in our 50s so
our longevity is you know maybe another
five or six years doing that so we're
looking to really hunker down and
and put some money somewhere else we're
we're technically we're technically
millionaires but most of it is in real
estate that we want to stay in in ag we
want to leave it to our our kids they
want to farm it and we want it to stay
in Farmland so we don't want to have to
sell it you know to live on to you know
we we're not looking to retire we don't
want to you're 100 debt free
yes sir and your taxable income this
year will be about what
[Music]
well we would tell you to put as much as
you can towards retirement and you
misquoted me I you said I say to put
money in what you know I say don't put
money in something unless you understand
it but just because you don't know about
something doesn't mean you can't go
learn about something it makes a great
life it makes a great livestock joke
that was a great line I loved it but you
need to go sit down with a good
smartvester Pro with the heart of a
teacher and start to learn enough about
mutual funds from someone with the heart
of a teacher that you get comfortable
doing some good mutual funds and both of
you need to open up Roth IRAs right now
okay and then you need to do more than
that probably but let's at least start
with two Roth IRAs
okay well and the beautiful thing is
that we've paid off over the years too
okay that could come in but good I mean
those well one of them we don't want
sold it's on the Farmland but I'm not
suggesting you sell them but you do need
to get Top Dollar Rental out of them and
manage them all the way to the wall
right
yes sir I'm just wondering if that's
what we should if we should throw our
money try to you know two Roth IRA is
only 16 000 a year
16 a year yeah that's not it's 8 000
bucks a piece for you too it's not it's
not gonna that's not gonna keep you from
getting a rental okay no I'm not going
to tell you to go into debt to go get
more rentals and I don't you don't have
any money right now much so I don't
think you're going to be buying a rental
anytime soon but let's get you a couple
of Roth IRA started and because I'd love
for you to look up in 10 15 years and
have two or three hundred thousand just
in those
okay and you could live off of that
money without having to cash out any of
the acreage
okay and I know it feels overwhelming
because because you're like you're
saying you don't know this area in this
space but the amount you're going to
need to learn is not a lot when you sit
down with a smart investor you need to
have somebody who has the heart of a
teacher but they're going to really walk
this through you so some of that
intimidation Factor once you sit down
with him that's going to go down and
we're not you don't need to become an
investment professional yourself you
don't need to understand exactly how all
the details of the stock market work you
just need to figure out you know the
best strategy for your money well you
got to understand the basics of what
you're putting your money in so that if
you hear something on the news it
doesn't freak you out and that's why
that's why I say don't put money in
something you don't understand because
if you do it because I said do it or
Christina said do it or some investment
professional should do it the first time
it goes sideways you're a little bit
you're going to go bananas but if you
know what's going on and you understand
the history of the market you understand
the history of what you're doing then it
doesn't it doesn't add stress it lowers
stress so knowledge is what keeps the
stress away no not just what keeps the
Panic away well what's interesting I
think right now for some reason real
estate and being a landlord seems easier
to a lot of people it seems like that's
going to be the lower stress way but
like we heard in a debt-free scream
earlier like we've heard in some of
these calls there's a lot of stress to
that that is not necessarily the easiest
way even if it seems easier because it's
a piece of property that's on you know
your land or something that seems a
little bit more familiar well real
estate well a good paid for rental house
if you purchased it properly and you
manage it properly we'll make you more
than mutual funds will make you but it's
also about 10 to 20 x more hassle I mean
with mutual funds all you got to do is
open up a computer and click
uh with rental property you've got to
deal with the heat and air guy you got
to deal with water heater going out the
Leaky Roof you got to deal with the
tenant that's
you know brought in 17 cats into your
house and the only way to get the cat
smell out is burn the house down I mean
you got to deal with all this stuff and
that's a whole different thing than just
opening a computer
and so you don't make as much on mutual
funds but you have nowhere near the
hassle so I believe in I personally have
a lot of both
uh but I'm willing as a landlord and
Abel as a landlord for 30 almost 40
years now managing my own properties and
with Rachel's husband Winston running
that part of our company uh to to take
on that stress and deal with that the
part of that but there's a hassle factor
involved that you're exactly right Dave
I feel like you probably have some good
landlord horror stories oh way too many
do you have an one that comes to mind
immediately
well I mean it's just the the thing it's
usually got to do with someone that
didn't believe us
when we said you have to pay your rent
you know I mean it's like what and uh
you know we're like no if you don't pay
your rent you have to leave oh here's
another one uh we went up on the rent
because the rental market went up
and so now we're not Christians
ouch because Christians can't go up on
the rent you know what kind of horse
crap is that that's absolutely
ridiculous so it's just dumber than a
rock I was wondering not Christian to
charge a market rate of course it's
Christian in Georgia market rate you
charge a market rate for your employer
when they pay you to work there and if
you don't get paid enough you go work
somewhere else that's not unchristian
that's just managing your life well but
yeah that's the kind of landlord stuff
you get you get everything in the world
you get all this emotion and all this
drama and all these other things in the
Residential Properties now the
commercial properties are a lot lot
easier I was wondering if the 17 cat
story was real
I've had them you know
I mean we've had them we have a no pet
policy we love we love dogs and don't
love cats but we don't even allow them
to have dogs I mean because they just
tear up everything yeah so we've got a
no pet policy and sometimes
they just choose to not abide by that
which means they choose to leave I was
hoping for something juicy Dave it's not
that juicy it's just drama this is the
Ramsay show
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Christine Alice Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
nine million Americans
were wrongly told they were approved for
student loan forgiveness
CBS news reporting about 9 million
Americans with student loans who had
applied for Biden Administration student
debt relief program mistakenly received
emails last month that said their
applications have been approved
the messages were part of updates the
Department of Education issued in
November to inform 16 million debt
relief applicants they've been approved
to have up to twenty thousand dollars
forgiven but an additional 9 million
people received emails saying they
received loan forgiveness when they had
not been approved for Relief because the
process was halted due to Legal
challenges and others who hadn't yet
applied for the student loan relief
program also received the email the
error was made by the federal Services a
contractor for the education department
which sent the emails the mistake may
only compound confusion among some
borrowers about the debt relief program
which for now remains in limbo due to
several legal challenges with the
Supreme Court earlier this month
agreeing to hear one of the cases in
February
oh
I saw this yesterday and this just
annoys me
come on there's enough confusion around
this already nine million people getting
an email saying they've been approved
why were there even emails sent out in
the first place saying they've been
approved when this hasn't passed
this program hasn't passed it's not in
action why were 16 million people quote
unquote approved when they haven't
actually been approved the program
hasn't been approved
well Biden had approved it and he had
issued the um the announcement but none
of the systems were in place to cause
the approvals to actually happen and
knowing that there were legal challenges
uh to his
program which may yet need a
congressional approval we don't know
we'll see
lots of stuff up in the air but given
all of that this is just again it's a
political play they accidentally told
50 percent more people that they had
approval than did accidentally
so at a minimum we have a
level of incompetence that is
only tolerated at the federal government
level
um I mean this level of incompetence I
mean if Ramsay Solutions sent out an
email to and and
to to
50 more people than we were supposed to
telling them we were going to give them
money I mean
can you imagine can you imagine yeah I
mean that level of incompetence in the
business world how we would have reacted
to uh the people internally that did
that right it would be a train wreck
yeah and instead they went oh oops well
and I think that's what's so crazy is
you know the 16 million people who got
the email that was you know supposedly
correct and then they're sending out
these refund checks how do they know the
difference about what's going on you
don't you don't you can't tell because
you don't know if you're got one of the
real emails or one of the ones that was
wrong but even if they got the real
emails there's still no forgiveness
because it's not been gotten through the
court system right so even if like the
semantics of the timeline of like this
16 million were before the court order
and then this nine Millions after right
now the reality is the program hasn't
passed
like right now it is still in limbo
there is no guarantee right now that
student loan forgiveness is going to
happen it might none no but there's not
a guarantee no guarantee none whatsoever
and um but I mean this is at a minimum a
gross level of incompetence or if you
want to be more cynical you could go
well they did this on purpose what do
you think Dave did they do this on
purpose
it's too large
to be an oopsie
I mean if you said okay 16 million and
we sent out
1 million
as an oops okay but nine million nine
you know the effort it takes to get nine
million emails out
that's not a you know one little guy
with two keystrokes
that's not how that works
so I mean uh I feel like okay so Dave
people have been asking me do you think
that there is any chance this program is
going to be approved and I know a lot of
people have strong opinions that they
feel like there's no way that it's going
to be approved but I kind of feel like
we have a government that is so obsessed
with debt that they've literally led us
trillions of dollars into debt they've
made Moves like this I mean I could see
it going both ways
in the sense of like they're not afraid
to put us more in debt
there's
you know there's so many things have
happened uh
in all areas of our society in the last
10 years that I thought would never
happen in my life so what do I know I uh
I certainly wish it was not going to be
approved but I don't uh and I don't
think it's going to be anytime soon and
I know for sure
that if you've got twenty five thousand
dollars in student loan debt and ten
thousand of it goes away with this that
I'm 100 sure you will not hate yourself
for just going and paying off your debt
because it is
your death there's that key part of it
too so you clean up your life and you
don't wait on the government to fix your
life I can't really figure out what the
flip they're gonna do it's the Island of
Misfit Toys you don't know where they're
going to come from next I you know what
they're playing politics with it for
sure
uh but it's under there somewhere
there's also the belief that they should
actually do this
um at some point and so I don't know how
long they got to wear out the court
system or they got to run it through
Congress what has to happen but oh my
gosh I feel like for me I'm you know if
it gets approved and people get their
loans forgiven like I will cheer for the
people who are out of debt I will cheer
for the people who had their debt
reduced what scares me though is what is
happening with kind of the trickery and
confusing people and that's where I'm
like go ahead and pay off your loans now
because that is the thing you can do to
control the situation this is so up in
the air I think this is really confusing
a whole generation on what the
responsibility is with debt and what
they need to do to to get control of
their finances so ah man it just breaks
my heart what's happening because I've
just I've seen the pain in people's
voices when they're like man I thought I
was debt free I was counting on this
twenty thousand dollars in student loan
forgiveness I'm a Pell Grant recipient
and then they're like wait wait what am
I debt-free or am I not and that's just
sad you can get debt free regardless the
this is what happens when you wait on
the government to fix your life all
right up next there's going to be Trevor
in Washington D.C hi Trevor welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey how's it going thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
um I think I'll just give a quick little
background in my question and we can go
from there does that sound good sure
cool so I'm 23 years old and I make 75
000 a year
um I have six thousand dollars of debt
and about 4 000 in the bank
um some halfway through Elise I lived
with my parents up until I was 22.
um the situation that had been occurring
repeatedly
um happened kept happening at my house
and made it unsafe for me to live there
so
um I did a very I it's a financially
dumb thing but I feel like it was what I
had to do at the time I just looked for
the closest apartment that would get me
out
um so I'm paying 2 000 a month to live
here and it makes me sick every time I
have to pay that
um and I'm not going to have a ton saved
up when my lease is up in six months
um I'm kind of just looking for some
advice on what some next steps could be
would you find a more affordable rental
yeah so that's that's one of my things
but um I've also just been thinking that
I know that buying a house is the smart
way to go you're broken
yeah you don't need to buy a house when
you're broke
it's not it's not a smart way to go
I guess the way that I was thinking
about it is it seems silly to me to have
to pay rent while also saving for a
house but I guess that's silly for you
to buy a house when you're broke because
Murphy will move in your spare bedroom
everything on the stupid house will
break and you'll look up near 60 000 in
debt trying to keep a freaking house
running owning a home is not necessarily
cheaper than renting as a matter of fact
it's oftentimes not cheaper than renting
uh on the Long Haul the fact that it
goes up in value and grows tax-free on
your personal residence up to a half
million dollars married filing jointly
it is a good investment and we believe
in home ownership but no I would not
tell you to go buy a house right now
what you need to do is go find a really
really cheap rental
you bought this room you went and picked
out a rental you couldn't afford because
you were emotional
now you're the other side of that crisis
hey Trevor stay on the line we're going
to gift you Financial Peace University
on us we want you to walk through this
so you can get the very clear path for
you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
Christina Allen's number one
best-selling author Ramsey personality
is my co-host today Jeff Is With Us in
North Carolina hi Jeff welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Dave thanks for your time
sure how can we help
um so I um my wife and I did your
financial Peach University class
um a little around two years ago and it
was a absolute phenomenal class we my
wife had ended up quitting her job
around the same time and we paid off way
more debt with one income than we ever
did with two I mean we've been a single
income family for the past two years and
we were doing quite well on baby step
number two
um we've had some unfortunate things
kind of happen and we kind of turned
into the ishpig and we're back down to
step one and we're trying to get gazelle
intense again and kind of want your
opinion on some guidance on what would
be the best route we've been working
with the law firm to try to get my wife
approved for disability she does have
some medical conditions and she was
denied once but they did state that she
was partially disabled so we're debating
whether continuing down that route is
the best route or she's talked about
going back to work to get a part-time
job um possibly with still being able to
take care of the kids to you know before
and after school or whether it would be
better for her to go back to college for
some kind of associate's degree so we're
just kind of debating on which route
would possibly be the kind of the best
benefit long term and I was kind of
hoping you could give your Insight or
your opinion on which one would
potentially be a good route to try to
continue to go towards
I feel like there's a bit more with the
situation so originally when she quit
her job did she quit to stay home with
the kids
her mother was um on hospice her mother
was had passed away and it was really
the only way she was able to spend time
with her mom
um and we so she had left her job and
she was a stay-at-home mom and after we
she was working a full-time job and the
amount she would we were paying for
daycare costs and the amount of money
she was bringing home after the amount
of daycare money we were paying it was
just I get a good amount of
opportunities for overtime in my job so
for the past two years it's just been
more cost effective for me to
consistently work overtime to help
compensate that lack of income how does
that make her disabled
uh she has a medical condition called an
ankylosis Spondylitis it's labeled as an
autoimmune disease and it's inflammation
of the spine so when you look at her
spine it's not aligned properly in her
pelvises but none of that none of this
not one time in this discussion did you
say she quit work because she was
disabled it was all other reasons she
quit work
had limitations
um she she enjoyed working and she
enjoys being a stay-at-home mom she
definitely
um we've been debating on what is the
best
um our family life is definitely we've
enjoyed the benefits of you know having
you know my wife home taking care of the
kids and we've enjoyed that opportunity
what does she want to do
she we're both kind of 50 50.
um she enjoyed working but she enjoys
being able to spend time with our kids
every single day
so it's really kind of just coming down
to money wise what is the best choice
um when I work overtime I typically make
a little over 30 dollars an hour in
overtime I mean
money if you just want more money it
always is going to involve more work
what can she handle if you say
money-wise money-wise it's always going
to be yeah work but if you're saying I'm
willing to trade off and I'll work
overtime so she can be home with the
kids then that's cool too but you you
know if you're only making the decision
on
money then you which is a bad way of
doing it but if you're only saying
money-wise then you would always go to
more work but there's there's an end to
that so you know you know based on her
uh physical limitations and her desire
to be home uh it doesn't sound like
she's going to be doing a lot of work
yeah
um yes that's definitely correct I mean
I wasn't sure if it would be even the
thought of maybe going back to school
for some kind of associate's degree
would but only if she wants to work
yeah which
right now she's partially disabled and
100 wants to be home with the kids
the only the reason this is on the table
is more money
correct I mean right now this time uh
We've definitely kind of had up and ups
and downs financially and what are you
trying to get gazelle intense uh about
50 000 A Year Without overtime and how
much debt have you got not counting your
house
uh we just actually sold our house and
we moved from Virginia to North Carolina
to kind of do a restart to pay off we
had about 20 000 in debt so right now
we're pretty much down to zero uh we
decreased our monthly expense not pretty
much
you don't have any debt
correct okay so you're debt free you're
renting and you make fifty thousand
dollars a year
correct good okay do you feel like you
all are still living ish
um yes absolutely we're we we absolutely
were doing this we've definitely within
the past month we've been trying to do
our family budget meetings every two
weeks
um we do kind of Google it's spell and
Google Excel spreadsheets you know to
kind of make sure we're budgeting down
to the dollar
um we definitely weren't doing that and
we definitely were ish so I'm going to
get the every dollar app it's a thousand
times better than stupid Google
when we did it it was um your class
Financial Peace University the every
dollar app was phenomenal yeah well you
get go get the app it's free and you can
run the basic Budget on it if you're
part of financial peace you can do the
expanded version and tie it to your bank
and all that but the Google spreadsheets
suck I wouldn't do that
um so I mean just do something and so
here's the thing
you guys need to make a list of the
things that uh and and then Force rank
their importance okay thing one okay
we're no longer ish we're gonna be
hardcore managing money
Thing Two
the pain the physical pain and
discomfort associated with disability
thing three I want to spend time with
the kids
in your wife's voice
thing
four I want to go back to school and
have a new career
thing five we want to save towards the
house
you cannot do all of these at one time
you cannot address the disability stay
home with the kids and work and go to
school and expand she cannot do it you
need to pick one and you need to go with
that one for now and you need to and say
so it sounds something like this okay in
order for her to be at home you are
working overtime and you are going to
stick to a freaking budget like your
life depended on it
right or
she's going back to school I'm going to
have a big career and I'm not going to
whine about not being with the kids all
the time
or about my disability
or you know whatever but let's pick a
plan and go all in on that plan that is
a sustainable plan mathematically well
and she should go get more work but if
you're living ish it's not even going to
feel like you're making more money it's
her income is not the problem right it's
it's that you guys are not you're trying
to do 73 things at once there's like
you've got to Force rank this stuff and
go okay I'm willing to pay a price
to be at home with the kids
or
you know it's inconvenient but for right
now I want to make more money and get us
back into a house in our new place in
North Carolina so for for right now for
this season I'm going to work like a
crazy person both of you
in all of these scenarios you're going
to get on your stinking budget and stick
to it
because it's what takes you to where you
want to go
it's the vehicle it's it's the the car
that's taking you to your destination is
the budget and it's the indication of
whether or not you're half butt doing
this stuff or not
and uh you gotta have to go okay because
you cannot half but do this stuff her
stay at home and
you guys it's not sustainable well and
if she goes back to work and she's
dealing with the pain associated with
that disability I don't want your money
to just be flying out the window if
she's willing to work and deal with all
that I want you all to actually see
progress from that yeah you really got
to kind of you need to turn the TV off
put the kids to bed and really kind of
write these things down and Force rank
them this is the most important one this
is the second most important one the
fifth and sixth ones you're not gonna
get today right now
that you're you don't have the bandwidth
no one does this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality is
our co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're in the holiday season where our
brains are focused on buying presents
and decorating our homes and all the
Christmas and New Year's celebrations
and then all of a sudden
it's January
and in some people's cases they wake up
in January with a financial hangover
and in other cases it's just a chance to
start fresh
and you recommit to no longer being ish
set yourself up to start the New Year
Strong by joining us for one of our
wealth building Live Events the first
one is here in Nashville on January the
12th it's a one night event and it'll
help you kick off 2023 feeling confident
about your money even in this crazy
economy join me and all the Ramsey
personalities as we walk you through a
simple but proven plan to get on track
and build wealth even in this weird
inflation recession crap going on it is
possible
we just wrapped up and sold out our fall
season we had a sold out spring season
before that this spring will sell out as
well it hasn't yet though you can still
get tickets again we're kicking it off
here in the Ramsey headquarters January
the 12th in Nashville February the 16th
is Indianapolis February the 23rd is
Austin Salt Lake City is April the 24th
and Anaheim is May the second passes
right now are 49 they will go on up
after the first of the year tickets for
these events always sell out early and
make sure you go ahead and get your
seats now by the way 49 makes a great
stocking stuffer for some of you the
Building Wealth live tour get your
tickets
ramsesolutions.com
events Danielle is in Biloxi Mississippi
hi Danielle how are you
hey I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
um I had a question my husband and I
have been married for nine years and
we've handled our finances pretty
terribly and we've kind of been having a
moment of Reckoning
um we've been looking into trying to
start budgeting but we've kind of gotten
ourselves in such a bind that
to start budgeting we're not really sure
how to
there's not a lot left out of each check
to be able to put back
so I got a log Jam how do we start yeah
what's your household income
um it depends he works a lot of overtime
he makes 28 10 an hour so give or take
he brings home about 1100 ish a week
so he's making fifty sixty thousand
dollars a year take-home pay so I'm
making 80 grand and you are at home with
the kiddos
yes sir I have three little girls okay
what age
they are eight
um my middle one will be six in about
three weeks and I have a one-year-old
and how much debt do you have not
counting your house
um I'm not counting our house it's
around 26
000 give or take
I don't know what vehicles uh a lot of
credit card that and our vehicle
and one or two loans what do you own in
the car
about nine thousand two hundred ish
other cars paid for
no sir we owe about nine I said the
other car is paid for
oh yes sir my husband's little truck is
paid for okay good
and he said that he's got he's been
working quite a bit of overtime how many
hours has he been doing a week
um he's putting it around
60 plus hours a week
okay it's about 20 over so does he seem
pretty maxed out in his ability to work
any extra yeah yeah he's exhausted I
mean he's he's still plugging along but
I don't know how to I want to know how
to help him and you know I can't go work
outside of the home with three kids by
the time you know I don't really have
any skills we're we're Christians we
believe in the Life staying home with
the children and so I don't really have
any skills as far as you know the
workforce so but even if I did find a
job all it would go to daycare so it
would be awesome rent or own your home
right now
we're paying a mortgage right now okay
and how much is that a month
975
okay
all right there's nothing in this math
that you gave us that screams stupid
okay okay but what you are you're dying
Death By A Thousand Cuts it's a lot of
little stuff
right and sometimes when I talk to
someone in your situation you know they
got a 32 000 car
okay and if you had a 32 000 car that
that would scream stupid okay and I'd be
going sell your stupid car okay you have
a nine thousand dollar car that's not
that's not crazy it's it's we got to get
rid of debt you can't breathe and life's
not good I'm not discounting that
situation but I don't see a single item
that if I pull that lever it changes
things quickly you don't have a single
item because you got a lot of little
ones does that make sense right yes sir
so what that ends up telling me is a
couple of things one is the two of you
uh resetting your minds and committing
to we are going to manage money instead
of it managing us
yes there's kind of a roar like
so going out to eat we are not going on
vacation
we are selling so much stuff the kids
think they're next and we're gonna do
the written budget and we're gonna stick
to it
and we're not gonna buy crap on the
Internet or crap at Costco or crap in
the mall and you kind of got to get mad
you hear what I'm saying
yeah my husband's kind of reached that
place he is so tired of working so hard
but you got to reach it you got to reach
it because you're the full-time home
economist
yeah right yeah which means pinching
these pennies Consignment sale clothes
our kids at the Ramsey house grew up and
experienced clothing okay
all right so I mean and then they went
to college debt free okay and and and
now they're grown-ups and none of them
are in counseling due to the clothing
that they didn't get
so that's right you know so I mean the
stuff that we all do in America and and
Danielle you are not doing anything
dramatically stupid but you're doing a
lot of little tiny stupid things that
are killing y'all
right that's exactly right and that's
that that's going to be where you can
give your husband a back rub
by saying I'm gonna make I'm gonna be
the coupon queen
I'm gonna cook from scratch and save
money
I'm not gonna whine about going out to
eat or going on vacation or whatever
and we're going to start punching this
stuff in the face and I'm emotionally
going to carry 60 of this
uh this Crusade that your family is
getting ready to go on to get your life
back
right because your credit card debt was
just when you got disorganized sloppy
and lazy
yes it was the worst that we ever did
was to get a credit card yep but I mean
it's just you did not do a single thing
with credit cards that was silly you did
lots of little things
right and by the way that makes you kind
of normal but normal sucks we don't be
normal anymore it's not fun right all
right so then then he's going to be more
energized because he's going to start
seeing
traction from his hard work and he can
work he can work 70 instead of 60. for a
short period of time because right now
he thinks he's going to do this his
whole life and I'm saying he's gonna
have to do this for two years
I can do anything for two years but I
can't do it for 20.
right and and so right now he feels like
a rat and a wheel because you're he's
working all the time and getting nowhere
right but if we're get if we're working
all the time and we're making traction
and we got rid of that credit card then
we got rid of that credit card then we
got rid of that credit card and now we
got the car off and God think about what
it'd be like to have no payments but a
house payment around your place
it'd be wonderful yeah I mean Lord Jesus
this would be fun
this would be good well and Danielle if
you if you want to work if you want to
contribute financially I wouldn't write
off your ability you know to figure that
out there's a lot of moms who watch an
extra kid or two in order to get a
little extra income so I mean dog walk
for the neighbor I mean and involve the
kids in it you can do all kinds of crap
that's that's 20 and 30 bucks an hour uh
and do 10 of those things a week you
know and never be away from your kids
you know you can do all that while
they're at school so you're you're
perfect we think people like you are
awesome because you are ready that's why
I'm excited for you that's where all
this volume is coming from so you hold
on we're going to put you through
Financial Peace University you and your
husband it's a nine lesson class you
hang on we're gonna pay for it because
and I want you to call me back and when
you're scared and when you're beat up
and when you don't know what to do we're
gonna cheer you on and then when you
finally make it we're gonna do a debt
free stream together
so you hang on the line Austin's gonna
pick up we're going to take care of you
kiddo
here you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show we're dead
as dog cash is king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Christina Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today our phone number if you
want to talk is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Nicole is with us
in Orlando hi Nicole how are you
hi I'm good and yourself better than I
deserve Merry Christmas to you how can
we help
Merry Christmas
um so my question today is two per
question
um the first part is should I sell my
payoff card to remove my debt quicker
and the second part also should I get a
fourth job as well
how much debt do you owe
so in total I owed 143
um now I'm down to 90. okay I it's all
my student loans Bachelor and master had
no idea about student loans and
um right now I'm making 80 83k
my income did up a great significant
amount this year
so uh to give you a little background
um my car is uh going for 24K per the
dealership offer and
um my three jobs is one is being a
medical social worker in the hospital
field as a full print position the
second one is a PRN which is as needed
and the third one is being a social
marketing for my family business
okay no I would not sell your car
your car is fine you're making really
good money you're not afraid of hard
work and you're game on how long you
been working on this get out of debt
plan
so Dave um to tell you the truth I've
been working on my debt Journey
um since 2000 well right when kovit came
in Thursday so almost
um in the middle-ish so a year I have
removed it a lot of my debt my credit
medical everything can think of all gone
including IRS and then I had to stop
um because I needed a mental break as a
social worker it takes a lot of impact
of your mental health so I took a break
and was able to go on a mini vacation to
take a deep breath and now I'm getting
back into it after six months
so how many days
how many hours a week are you working
so technically I work 40 hours a week
but when I pick up my PRN it will be
about six feet out no yes 60 hours in
one week and then when I'm working on my
family business I'm working to 80 to 100
hours a week so is the 83 based on the
83 000 you're making is that based on
your primary job or all three jobs
together
all three jobs my primary job is 61 000
my PRN is 3
000 in annual and then my family
business is 18.
okay why would you work on the PRN for
only 3K
it's a key
relationship with a well-known
organization I need money
true
yeah true
um so what I'm what I would do and if
I'm not going to sell the car and I'm
not is I'm going to do the most high
paying thing
because I want to get this over with
then I'll worry about long-term plays
which the PRN is a long-term play
a cash a cash grab is a short-term play
and right now you're looking for
short-term plays
right Dave can I see a question
um I see you like a father figure
because I don't have a father in my life
um
if if I go ahead and let go the PRN
um would it be an option of keeping it
and signing up for more days and hours
with them because while I'm off at my
primary job I can pick up the weekend
and I'll be working every single day but
I can do my my family business at night
and then the hospital days throughout
the week what are your thoughts the
thing is here what I'm looking for is
what gets you out of debt the fastest
because that is your best career move
okay now if you can if you you know I
don't think you're gonna lose the PRN by
setting it on the shelf for 18 months
are you
I have to give two days out of the month
to be permanent in that position in that
second job
okay but I'm saying you can go back to
that job
oh yes if you just said you know you can
still go be PRN
but you just have to restart is all
yes I can do that yeah as well so all
I'm asking is where do you make the most
money
my full-time
for your side jobs where you're you're
because all we're doing here is I mean
if you can make 15 000 more at one of
these things than another on the side
gig let's go do that and get this debt
gone that much faster
and before you run out of steam again
right I'm still wondering how it
register you to the
full because with a master's degree and
the experience you have there's a chance
you could get a higher paying job as
your primary potentially getting you up
to that 83. yeah I I appreciate you
asking that question
um I'm actually put a pause on my LCSW
so I can remove my which is licensed
clinical social worker
um I put that on a pause because my debt
was overbearing me
um so if I go ahead back on track
setting and pass my license I can up my
annual income and get a different side
job by maybe how long would that take 20
grand
yeah uh
is to get the date of exam it will take
about approximately two to three months
and then after that I can know on the
spot if I passed or not okay but it's
depending
um so if if we don't do that and we say
all right we're going to take the most
efficient highest paying cash grab
um are you out of debt in
a year and a half
I want to do less than a year to be
honest with 90 000 bucks
yes sir no you don't pay off less than a
year on making 83 you don't pay off 90.
if that makes sense yeah okay but I mean
if you're gonna have to get your income
to one Thirty to pull it off in a year
uh or or 120 anyway pull it off near if
you can do that that's fine but I'm with
you then then let's go get let's make
the move up and that kind of stuff
because we're not talking about a
three-year Journey here we're talking
about 12 14 16 month Journey and
you know I'm gonna give up a few
long-term plays right now to get this
out of the way and be done with it
forever and ever amen because the
beautiful thing is once you kick Sally
Mae out she ain't coming back
and that's that's the that's what I want
her in your rear view mirror she's an
ugly woman this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
Christine Alice Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you've gone through
Financial Peace University chances are
it's because someone in your life lit a
fire under you your mom or dad gave it
to you as a gift your pastor offered it
to you at the church maybe a mentor at
work or a friend that just wouldn't shut
up about FPU that's the best kind of
friend by the way uh so you finally took
the class you started working the baby
steps now you got out of debt you're on
your way to being a baby step
millionaire
now you can return the favor and light a
fire under someone else this Christmas
you can give someone you care about
Financial Peace University and share the
same hope that you've discovered with
money when you give FPU as a gift they
won't just get the course they also get
the premium version of every dollar and
group coaching with our team of
financial coaches so this Christmas give
the people you care about a gift that
actually matters
it's called hope
it's called freedom
to give Financial Peace universities a
gift go to ramsaysolutions.com give FPU
that's ramseysolutions.com
g-i-v-e-f-p-u that's how it works
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Amy is with us Amy is in
Indianapolis Indiana hi Amy how are you
hi I'm doing well how are you better
than I deserve what's up in your world
all right well
um my question is do I pay off my
mortgage so um here's my background I'm
37 I'm married with three kids I am
currently homeschooling my kids so I am
not working my husband works full time
um and we are kind of at the point where
we're struggling to make ends meet
um I'm having a hard time convincing him
of a budget so that's kind of that's
where we're butting heads
um so my mortgage or I should say our
mortgage is at 263
000.
um I have I inherited a bit of money
from my father about 14 years ago when
he passed it has helped us through lots
lots of um uh problems we've paid off a
few mortgages here and there and I've
just been kind of tossing the idea
around should I take out some or some
money and get rid of this mortgage
what's a bit of money how much money is
there
well it could it currently set
thousand so what does your husband make
a year
he currently is making 65
000 plus commission and commission is
you know kind of not hit or miss he's
still building up clientele
um so I'm going to give it about an
extra 20 000 a year so when you paid off
the other mortgages you didn't change
your habits and continued to drain this
inheritance a little bit at a time
because you've refused to be disciplined
and most likely yes yes is that what you
told me or not
yes that is that is correct and we had
so we both build our current home had it
paid for why is this one
well because we decided to start a
business and so we I mean when you pay
off this mortgage and you still have no
discipline why is this time going to be
different than the other times
I know I know
it's it's come down to do I go back to
work
and no it didn't send the kids to school
and nope nope it didn't
No it didn't
it's come down to it's time for you all
to decide to be grown-ups and manage
this money instead of leaning on this
inheritance to allow you to continue to
be undisciplined
yes that's what it's come down to
so it's the husband on the budget thing
it's you on a budget thing it's the two
of you learning to live on what you make
right right if you do that for six
months I'd write a check and pay off the
house
these mortgages that you've paid off
were they on your primary residence or
do you have rental property
no we don't have any rental property so
and you know we kind of started out with
a smaller house you know had that paid
off and then took that you know
obviously the what we made from that put
it on the next house and this is not
sustainable
right yes yes
it's not sustainable and you yeah uh you
know doing something else and trying to
figure out a way to make it sustainable
because what you've got to do is you got
to get a set of habits that you and your
husband communicating you guys living on
a written game plan and you're setting
goals and we're being grown-ups instead
of just kind of like I'll just go over
there and get some money out of that
inheritance every time I have a problem
instead of addressing the issues in my
mirror I'm just going to go over and hit
the inheritance am I picking on you too
hard does that mean
no I just wish somebody else was here to
hear that as well you can play it back
it'll be on the podcast
yes and you know other than that we're
debt free and the only additional aside
from normal you know monthly expenses is
child support so
um you know I feel like if we yeah we
just need to get our act together and
get on the same page with with a budget
and yeah you're covering your
you're you're treating the symptom
instead of the problem
right right right and that that's what
I'm picking on you about because it's
not it's not good for you it doesn't
affect us obviously we're going to hang
up and go on with our lives but uh but
but for you guys I want you guys to have
this sense of power as a couple
that having a written game plan and a
and aiming at something together for the
future holds because if you can function
and I think you could function
beautifully on his income without a
mortgage but I don't want you to
function on his to not even because your
track record is you're going to pay off
this mortgage and then you're going to
continue to be sloppy and go back into
debt again that's your track record
right yeah yeah because you never
treated the core issue
well Amy you said your husband's not on
board but are you on board like are you
ready I am I'm I have been so ready I
probably I think I have three of your
books sitting on my on my desk that I've
been reading and I'm ready to kind of
you know punch out numbers and go and
let's let's get him into Financial Peace
University and the two of you start
doing that together and the way that
sounds is this and we're going to give
it to you free okay because we want to
help you with this and so my if if
you're asking for like the doctor to
give you a prescription to take to the
pharmacy okay here's what it is okay the
two of you are in agreement like never
before
and you're managing your household
in a way that makes you proud
two of you together for six months
and then you'll look at each other and
write a check and pay off the mortgage
and you'll be just fine because you will
affixed the underlying thing and we're
not going to leave
everything in danger because uh uh so it
that that's what I would have you to do
and we'll help you do that we'll put you
guys into Financial Peace University and
so the way that sounds then is when he
gets home is not he's the bad guy he's
not the bad guy here you're the bad guy
both of you are the bad guys you're but
it's not it's not there's not a bad guy
that's not the point but you're you're
the the the
you both allowed this situation
and it was it's a it's not like
grotesque laziness it's a minor laziness
like you're 10 lazy
you're not you're not 90 lazy you kind
of know what to do and you're doing okay
but you've accepted okay and usually the
enemy of awesome is not bad it's okay
okay is the enemy of awesome because you
can kind of get by on okay
you know yeah you know and so that I
want you to get out of okay into awesome
that's all I'm begging you to do so the
way you should sit down with him and
just say listen I I want you to do this
for me the two of us go through these
nine lessons together in the next three
weeks before the first of the year
okay and then at the first of the year
we need to sit down as a couple and have
a vision for our future
and let's lay that out because the
stress of this and this gnawing thing
that we're slowly eating away at this
inheritance instead of dealing with our
core issues it's it's driving me crazy
and I need you to do this for me and do
it as this is my Christmas gift I want
you to go through these nine lessons
with me that's a cool Christmas gift
yeah and just you know he loves you and
say this is an act of love to your wife
I know you don't want to do it I know
you don't want to deal with it but I
want us to sit and go through these nine
lessons together
and and let me just tell you if both of
you sit and watch all nine of these
lessons in the next three weeks
he'll be on board
I'll get him I know how to do it you get
him in Financial Peace I'll get it I'll
get him on board so hang on Austin will
pick up and we'll get you guys signed up
as our gift Merry Christmas
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
Christine Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they are the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
always use the promo code it's magical
the name is Ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from Ariana and
Maryland my husband and I are on baby
steps four through six our children are
11 9 4 and 3. we've been putting around
a thousand dollars a month into their
529s but much more into the 11 and 9
year olds since they will be going to
college sooner however I was wondering
if it would be smarter to put more money
into the younger two children's 529s
since there's a lot more time for that
money to grow we've told our kids we
will cover the cost of in-state tuition
in full and don't want them taking out
any loans I like that our annual income
is three hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year we have 315k left on our
mortgage and we hope to pay it off in
the next five years we currently pay
twenty five hundred dollars a month in
child care for the two younger kids so
I'm thinking we could cash flow college
for the oldest two even if we have a
little left on the mortgage
that's a great question there's a lot to
unpack there you're doing a good job
yeah and they've got great income so
that's awesome and I love that they've
already put that line in the stand that
loans aren't an option I think the
biggest thing right now is just getting
super tactical and getting a really
Clear Vision of you know what exactly
are those numbers that need to happen in
order to make you know cash flowing
College realistic so you know right now
it sounds like the numbers are kind of
squishy you guys are doing a great job
putting a thousand dollars a month away
but I want you to get onto a college
savings calculator which we have one at
ramseysolutions.com you can search
college savings calculator and you can
actually type in the college you're
thinking about and how much longer you
have until your kids going to college
and then see how much you need to be
saving per month in order to hit that
goal so you know figure that out also if
you want to get super tactical sit down
with a smartvestor pro who can kind of
see your whole financial picture and
they can do the same thing they can walk
you through how much you need to be
saving each month for each kid in order
to reach that goal and then once you
have those numbers down it's really
about prioritizing what's most important
to you you so you know paying off the
house that's also awesome you know and
if you find that to save for the four
children it's a little bit more than you
want to do in terms of the balance
between the house and savings I mean
that's that's going to be more a
decision of what's right for your family
because you could with a 350k a year
income you've got a really good shot at
Cash flowing that yeah so uh
mathematically if you said I want enough
in the 529 when each one of them get
there
to pay cash for in-state tuition and
dorm and books okay
then you get that number and be very
clear as Christina said and you say okay
then based on that for the 11 year old I
have to save X
for the three-year-old I have to save Z
and you can you can come up with the
exact number you need to be saving and
if when you add all four of those
numbers together to fully fund it you
say oh I don't want to do that that's
too much
I'd rather put more towards the mortgage
and come up short on
one but when you if you were to do that
fully funded idea you're going to see
that the 11 year old's a lot more than
three-year-old because as you said I
mean as she you know Ariana says in the
email she's correct that you know it's
closer to college so you don't have much
time so uh it doesn't take it's going to
take a minuscule amount for the
three-year-old versus what it takes for
the 11 year old you got seven years or
six years and uh you know versus uh 15
years so it's a whole different really
substantial difference on the math so
but so you would be putting in more for
the older ones if you choose to fully
fund all four simultaneously so that's
what the math tells you so I'm going to
kind of lean that direction even if we
choose not to fully fund
and put more towards the mortgage now if
you choose not to fully fund you say
okay I'm gonna need a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars for the 11 year
old I'm just making up a number okay
um and I'm only gonna be at 90.
okay so I'm 40 short the way I'm going
to cover the 40 is I'm not gonna have
daycare anymore and I'm gonna be making
350. we're gonna cash flow 40. we're
gonna have
the uh the 90 okay and so if you're
going to come up short then you're
saying out loud I'm going to cash flow
that much more when they do get there
and so uh what I would do is either
fully fund all of them with unequal
amounts heavier on the 11 lighter on the
three Euro or underfund all of them
with unequal amounts
and then plan the cash flow there you
know as you go there or option three you
could say uh we're going to cash flow
the last two
almost completely the two older ones
because they're kind of separated out
here you got a four and a three and a
nine eleven so you kind of got two
buckets Worth right uh because we're
gonna have the house paid off by the
time the three and the four-year-old get
there and we're going 100 cash flow of
those so we're putting hardly anything
in there that's another way you could
run the math any of those will work
and it's just no matter how you want to
play it out but it's a really great
thing that you're paying attention in
both of our answers what you heard was
get more detailed in your analysis and
in your decision so you're intentionally
saying I'm going to save in such a way
that I'm going to be 40 000 short
and you have those numbers down yeah and
and here's how I'm going to cover that
40. or I'm going to save in such a way
that I'm not going to be short for this
kid and this kid but the other two we're
going to catch low and pay off the house
or but but this idea I'm putting in a
thousand and I think it's all going to
be okay no no no no you need to drill
deeper that's what you said and I agree
with you yeah and I think I mean I've
talked to so many parents who are just
overwhelmed when they get to College
costs that they kind of just stick their
head in the sand and they don't want to
think about it but it's like you can
actually tactically work through these
numbers they don't have to be so scary
they don't have to stay squishy you know
you can actually map these out have a
plan even if it's intimidating and even
if you're going to be disappointed with
how much you can contribute I'd rather
you you know even if you're sending
aside 25 a month in a 529 and that's not
enough to cover the full cost of college
you're doing something for the first
time
since I've been on the air
it is an unknown
what you're going to spend on that
three-year-old
you could have projected it
but now we've had this tremendous
upheaval of higher ed
brought on by their ridiculous expense
because they just keep driving the
tuition through the roof the Epic
student loan crisis and then they tried
to charge everybody full price when they
went home from covet
and try to do it online at the same
price and everybody went no no no no no
no no no no I am not paying full price
with no college experience uh just
because I go on the computer and take a
test no no no no so higher ed has got a
real black eye right now and a lot of
people are choosing to say no college at
all which I don't believe in or they're
choosing to say no learning at all no
certifications at all no you've got to
have post high school education of
something to be a welder a diesel
mechanic a code
coding expert with Ruby on Rails or uh
or go get four-year degrees okay in
different things but you need to go get
posted post classical education in
something but what you do it or how you
do it is going to change
so a lot of stuff that
10 years ago we would have said a
four-year degree now we're saying
probably not
you're probably going to do some shirts
and some certifications and you're
probably going to rock on and have a
life of continual learning but not to
necessarily take the form of IV on the
side of the wall right well the cool
thing though too with a 529 is it can
cover that it can pay for a lot of
different certifications trade school
whatever what I'm saying is they can't
predict I'm going to go to this school
and pay this because a
that school might not cost what we think
it's going to cost because there's going
to these things are going to get turned
on their heads people are pissed off at
higher ed and so and they're they're
abandoning so their ability to just
charge whatever the crap they want to
charge is gone but that doesn't mean
don't plan no I don't want people to say
but what I'm saying is you can't if you
project out the way we used to project
out and you get 160 000 in your
projections it might not be hopefully
it's not I bet you it's not I bet you I
bet you it's going to be less because I
think they're going to get it I think
they're gonna get their nose punched in
and some of them are going to have to
like straighten up and fly right or
income based repayment will be a thing
and then people will go crazy with it
hopefully that doesn't happen no we're
not doing that one that's not the thing
please don't know
hey it's a great discussion be
intentional and detailed that's the sum
of the answer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Deuteronomy 31 6 be strong and
courageous do not be afraid or terrified
because of them
for the Lord your God goes with you he
will never leave you nor forsake you
John Wayne said courage is being scared
of death but saddling up anyway
open phones this hour Christina Ellis
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host
Jennifer is with us in St Louis hi
Jennifer how are you
I'm great how are you guys better than
we deserve what's up in your world
what's up is I just found you where have
you been all my life
I just found you about two months ago
from a dear friend uh she wouldn't stop
talking about you so I checked it out
and then I've been listening to you ever
since
I'm just not quite to my confidence
level for the question I have today so I
wanted to call in fair enough
um so I'm working on my own baby steps
but this is for my son
I was never taught by my parents
anything that you speak of at all so
this is all I've been learning this the
hard way for many years most most
weren't
right right should be taught in high
school
um but while I'm working on my own my
son is getting ready to turn 18 and
after listening to one of your whole
life episodes
I I realized that he had I was paying
for a whole life for him and I switched
it to terms
and the cash out that is coming his way
is only twenty five hundred dollars but
that's still
money I've been putting away I guess
with this for the past few years so I'm
not going to let him know that he has it
um I just want to
figure out what's the best step forward
what do I do with that 2500 if I hand it
to him he's just gonna he's just gonna
blow it he's like oh this is awesome I'm
rich he's gonna go spend some on 8017.
but he's coming up in you know his
birthdays in January how do I advise him
or what do I do with this money do I put
it in a Roth do I put it in a 401k he
do I invest I wouldn't do either one of
those what was the purpose of you saving
the money
I really I really wasn't I just for his
for his future End quotes
yes yeah no kind of vague in other words
it didn't have a particular Target it
doesn't and it's hard to find it because
okay so anything he spends it on short
term it was not your dream for this
money your dream was long-term
he's he is set short term well he's a 17
year old of course he's short-term yeah
we have a plan for that and it's in
where he's going but for this money no
it was it was meant for future or at
least the whole life that I thought he
knew is he is he going to college
he has a GI Bill but he's actually going
to do an apprenticeship for a trade uh
I'm a Tradesman and cool what he doesn't
I'm sorry what's his trade
uh I'm a Tradesman right now he is
actually going to go for either uh
welding or Plumbing good he's testing
him out to figure out which one he likes
better that's fun okay well he'll
probably need the 2500 to complete the
whole apprenticeship program and get
some of the certifications won't he
foreign
I don't think so because he has the GI
bill which will cover
it's going to cover everything I guess
it will you're probably right okay
um Okay so
you're you're
if we could if we could go back in time
for the rest of our listeners
we would have started this discussion
many many years ago
so that he didn't like feel like he hit
the lottery so I in other words if
um
it's always best if you can start
talking to a 10 year old about what it's
going to be like when he's 18 and that
this money is a responsibility not a
lottery winning
um this is not a Vegas weekend this is
an opportunity to do wonderful things
for your future and this 2500 if played
right could be worth 250 000 to you
whether it's invested in education
whether it's uh invested period uh
whatever it is so you start talking
about you know that money is a
responsibility it's not a woohoo
but that's you're behind on that so you
got an 18 year old 17 year old you got
to just start that discussion cold and
so I'm not bringing up the 2500 today uh
if but I'm also not going to hide it
indefinitely I'm just going to put it
over in your checking account and go
okay I'm or not even checking account
put in a separate savings account
earmark it for him and then sometime in
the next three or four years figure out
with him as you continue some
discussions but it might sound like hey
I'm learning some new things son and I
wish that uh I didn't learn them this
late but you're going to get the benefit
of those things I'm learning about money
as we go along so there's some money set
aside and earmarked for you I'll come
back to that later it's not yours today
but it's there to help you get some of
these things done just like that GI
bills help you here to help you get some
of these things done and so as we walk
together and we make some great
decisions for your future and you make
some great decisions for your future uh
maybe maybe it helps you buy a house
someday maybe it helps you finish up
your one of your certifications if the
GI Bill didn't cover it or maybe it's
there but there's it's not up this is
not a chance for you to go to Vegas or
it's not a chance for you to uh you know
head of the Bahamas for the weekend or
something that's not what it's for well
and especially I mean I've worked with
so many 17 18 year olds and parents that
encounter unexpected expenses with their
education and I mean twenty five hundred
dollars that could make a big difference
especially if you know there's
unexpected certifications or books that
come up that somehow aren't covered so
it's like having that money accessible
is super important yeah for today I'm
going to go open a savings account in
your name and set it in there doesn't
need to earn any money we've got to get
through this transition right now Dave
I've got a question question so that
money from the whole life insurance is
that technically the son's money or is
that her money
it's her money she's the owner of the
policy right so that money's coming back
to her so that's not even technically
his his but it's her it's in her name
and and she's earmarked it for him and
you can give somebody 2500 with no gift
tax so she could do she can give it to
him anytime in her mind it's his money
am I right
Jennifer yes yeah that's exactly right
you're not legally obligated is uh
Christina's point to give it to him
and so if he's if he's going to be
stupid on steroids we're not giving it
to him right because we don't want to
finance as stupid we want to finance his
future
well then there's not even really the
obligation necessarily to tell him until
you do want to get back but I want to
begin the training
um I want to begin to have this
conversation and just lightly begin to
let them know what's going on what's
going on what's going on what's going on
and so we're we're training him over the
next 18 to 24 months to make good
decisions or better decisions that he
might today well that's a great training
ground because you can train them and
have those conversations but there's no
point at which you can say hey that's my
money give it to me right like there's
no point at which you can say legally
well if he gets entitled like that yeah
you don't have to give it to him but
yeah yeah that's true you're not you're
not over the mom's not over a barrel if
he goes cray-cray on her yeah that's
true so yeah that's true that's a that's
a valid point so you've got a lot of
power here to play this for his own good
well and it gives a lot of freedom to
really teach those lessons and
regardless of how how it goes like
you're still in control of managing that
money yeah and then just don't be you
know and if you if you kind of get to
talking about and you go you know what
let's use this for your first house
purchase and you're probably going to do
that at 25 and you're 18 now so we got
seven years let's go ahead and talk to a
mutual fund broker you and I'll go sit
down with a mutual fund broker and let's
put this money in a mutual fund and
we'll both learn about how to do that
and we'll both do this as a have a
meeting with a smartvester pro and sit
down they smart Mr Pros by the way love
meeting with 18 year olds and doing 2500
deals uh they don't love doing 2500
deals but they love the idea that
they're investing in the future with
somebody
and helping somebody that's getting
started well and that's potentially a
client for Life they're starting from
the very beginning yeah I mean they
don't even make enough to cover the
postage to mail the crap in you know
only 2500 but that's not but they still
love doing it but if you can get an 18
year old saving and investing it's like
the sky is the limit that's how you get
baby step millionaires who are 30.
that's or late 20s that's just going to
be really impressive so
um hang on the line let's get her into
Financial Peace University and let's
have them go through it together
a really cool you know mother-son
experience that'd be fun so hang on
Austin will pick up and we'll get you
guys signed up for that so great show
today guys Austin Ben James Zach Andrew
and the booth the booth dudes it caused
it to happen as they always do Christina
Grace show good job we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
foreign
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
foreign